qu'en dit qu'est ce que c'est alors ça
c'est bien passé ta promenade en vie
julie mal très mal
j'avais noté plein de choses que je
voulais voir je n'ai rien vu du tout
qu'est-ce que tu cherchais je voulais
voir des vaches des cochons un tracteur
des grenouilles betis est quand même
mieux fait d'aller à la campagne pour
trouver des grenouilles et un tracteur
et des vagues à bonds
merci casimir tu es formidable pourquoi
j'ai rien fait mais si tu viens de me
donner l'idée d'un jeu j'étais en train
d'en chercher un arbre désigné rues et
les enfants et les voix ont donné
martelant venus voir les corps casimir
ferrer shalit et d'un je voulais qu'on
le fasse ensemble d'accords bon alors on
s'installe dans l'herbe là on s'assied
par terre voilà comment ça va se passer
je vais vous dire tantôt le mot ville
tantôt le mot campagne il devrait me
donner pour chaque mot un nom d'objets
d'animal ou ce que vous voulez que l'on
ne trouve pas normalement à la ville si
je vous dis le mot ville et qu'on ne
trouve pas normalement à la campagne si
je vous dis le mot campagne c'est
compris ici aussi tout le monde a
compris
même quasi 1000 watts bien sûr bien sûr
alors que c'est mieux
campagne papé pourquoi péter pâté de
campagne la bonne astuce meinau c'est
mauvais quasi missamou du pâté de
campagne et la campagne ça revient oui
julie ville il la forêt forêt pas de
format la ville campagne je les
immeubles ils meurent akram y avait tout
de suite tu es fan je te dis campagne
autobus très bien quoi autobus à je te
dis film marche très bien
on ne trouve pas de vache à la ville bon
allez michel campagne feu rouge feu
rouge contre pas de feux rouges à
campagne très bien fait et exotiques
charlie charlie parfait mais pas plus
moi la campagne
alors casimir est soufflé quelque chose
dégoûtante compagne et les formes
campagne à l'éléphant très bien et s'il
se dit ville heureusement que tu es
souffrir chose qu'on trouve pas la ville
à la mer par exemple
y a pas la mer à tous alors maintenant
bon alors je te dis campagne tout à fait
tour eiffel très bien alors mais tout va
très bien compris maintenant je te dis
film c'est un serpent très bonne réponse
à toi pascal qui en forme
alors on y va aller ville qu'est ce
qu'on trouve pas la ville et vêtir un
ver de terre
enfin toujours en grade très très
profondément de sous les pavés peut-être
enfin tu as tu as raison en général et à
la trappe
et si je te dis campanile
bonsoir ah si il ya des lézards à la
campagne par exemple tu ne trouves pas
le mauvaise air pollué des villes à la
campagne ainsi qu'à la ville
souvent tu gardes champêtres ne suis pas
d'argent qui se sait qu un garde
champêtre magasin un peu dit fier de la
campagne champêtre à ya le mot change
qu'on peut être un policier deschamps
campagne petite plaie à l'ailé mais pas
fléchi de gendarmerie oui dans la
campagne c'est vrai ya pas de ya pas de
caserne des gendarmes
irène campagne alors pour toi trottoir
là c'est bien à la campagne
y a pas de trottoirs dans les chemins de
campagne exil quelque chose ou quelqu'un
qu'on trouve pas à la ville une ferme
très bien à meneur ville
une oie une oie parfait padoue à la
ville campagne parcmètres ya pas de
parcmètres à la campagne on line et
avait tout de suite de bonnes réponses à
toi et je dis campagne quelque chose
qu'on trouve pas à la campagne
l'éclairage au néon effectivement jean
des choses qu'on ne trouve pas la ville
un tracteur parfait ah oui j'avais pas
vu là vous avez tous compris
c'est elle qui signe à sorel oui oui
mais hilali avait raison que j'ai pas vu
de tracteurs à la campagne à la ville
oui de toute façon ça ne m'intéresse pas
et se jouait trop compliqué parce que je
ne devais aller ni à la ville ni à la
campagne parce que je suis très bien ici
dans le jardin de l'île aux enfants
n'est ce pas unique c'est le plus bel
endroit ah oui c'est vrai tu as raison
je voudrais même offert un tableau si je
pouvais
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec beaucoup de couleurs
avec beaucoup de douceur
[Musique]
je voudrais faire
le tri
mais
j'ai des garçons
casimir show de sa chance
vos jeux
ah ah
mais je l'aurais mis au pas si je vais
je leur ai mieux peu si j'étais un
enfant
[Musique]
ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans le kiosque que les poupées
on les aime
coli
couleurs série
c'est tout
m
à papillons passe
pas si sûr
[Musique]
utile
mais je peux mieux si je disais
mais je
si j'étais à l'entente
oh
[Musique]
ça
à
[Applaudissements]